the narrative that bitcoin has not gone
up as a safe haven asset wrong the fact
that bitcoin has not served as a good
inflation hedge asset wrong bitcoin
literally when the pandemic started was
at eight thousand dollars that forty
three thousand dollars now there was not
another asset in the world in terms of
like a macro asset class that you should
have run to for inflation
gold is still trying to figure out how
to just keep up with inflation let alone
beat it bitcoin is up hundreds of
percent and i think that's what people
are starting to recognize now is that
the public narrative comes from people
who they their whole world is centered
stocks and bonds
bitcoin of cryptocurrencies this little
tiny thing over here
we don't want to talk about that on tv
we'll put on our website
oh we don't want to have the whole show
be about that we'll have one person come
on a segment
i spend 95 of my day researching stocks
i was telling somebody yesterday i said
young people don't want stocks
stocks are dumb
according to most young kids what do
they want they want to understand where
the future is they want to understand
asymmetry and they want to hold assets
that they have a higher degree of
confidence in right now if you had to
choose would you choose bitcoin or would
you choose
i don't know ibm amazon's a good example
amazon
bitcoin will outlast amazon
period
not because amazon's bad amazon's an
amazing company
hence why it's one of those valuable
companies in the world but if you look
out a hundred years
which one is more likely to be here
bitcoin or amazon is no question in my
mind bitcoin is the more durable asset
and so i think a lot of people take that
it's like oh my god you're [ __ ] on
you know amazon or whatever yeah but
it's not that it's just the fact that
what we're talking about is durability
and that durability is definitely in a
decentralized digital currency that has
been adopted by a 150 plus million
people around the world bitcoin has more
shareholders than amazon does bitcoin
has more customers than amazon does
it's more popular hey you did you like
this video great we make five of them a
day and post them here on this channel
make sure you subscribe like the video
and see you next time